man bro let me tell you what had went
down and I was two beds away from
getting bro whole Barbershop bro yeah oh
my mama bro peanut gonna call my phone
talking about I just got paid I looked
at the phone you just got paid what man
what the dice at I'm ready to shoot we
can roll last time I shot with him 1300
in my pocket
off top off top easy what happened what
happened man peanut is what happened had
me high on my mama hot seven seven seven
seven back to back to back to back bro I
was mad he was in bro he was all in my
bag in my pockets in my whole Duffy I
was ready to get out
especially what he is saying
he saved up his money to get a local
barber shop he then made a friendly
business wager with peanut and hopes to
secure more money for his business but
eventually losing it off with one roll
of the dice
right what you think I think volatility
is his problem and I don't think he
understands how to compound his talent
and how could it compound his money what
I mean is if you just take big bets like
that you'll blow it all you can you
should invest in yourself man and then
you learn more and then when you learn
more you also make more money and it
compounds you could have two barber
shops you could have ten businesses if
you know how to compound
basically bro what he's saying is slow
money wins the race you could still have
a big upside even if you don't throw all
your chips in the bag invest in yourself
leave them dice alone you don't need to
invest in the dice
that's gonna ruin everything
spread your money out let it build for
yourself and work gradually slowly
anybody that's ever made a lot of money
to make it fast you feel me feel you off
top
PG Lane